[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره الظهيره من
العربيه ساعه اخباريه مفصله نبداها بابرز
العناوين
غالبيه الدول الاعضاء في مجموعه العشرين
تدين الحرب في اوكرانيا ورئيس اندونيسيا
يدعو لوقف الحرب
مسؤولون امريكي
ما شاء الله
[تصفيق]
باخراج بيض من البيت الابيض
اهلا بكم في البدايه من بالي من اندونيسيا
ومجموعه العشرين عربيات مجموعه ال 20 على
اساسها بشده اتجاه استمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا وذكر البيان ان معظم الدول
الاعضاء ادانت وبشده العدوان الروسيه على
اوكرانيا لكنه هناك وجهه نظر اخرى كما
اشار البيان الى ان التهديد بالسلاح
النوويه او استخدامه امر مرفوض تماما
المجموعه تاكدت استمرار دعمها للقانون
الدولي والنظام متعدد الاطراف لتحقيق
السلام والاستقرار واضاف البيان ان الحرب
في اوكرانيا
ستواصل تجديد السياسه النقديه لكن بشكل
مناسب
وعلى هامشي قمه ال 20 اقرب رئيسه تركيه
رجب طيب اردوغان عن ثقته في تمديد اتفاق
تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود والذي
ينتهي اماده السبت المقبل وقال اردوغان ان
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الذي ابرم بواسطه
الامم المتحده سمح لنحو احد 10 مليون طن
من الحبوب بدخول الاسواق العالميه اشار
اردوغان ايضا الى ان المؤشرات الاقتصاديه
العالميه تظهر ان الوضع الحالي قد يصبح
اسود واعرب عن استعداد تركيا لاستضافه
مباحثات سلام مباشره ما بين روسيا
واوكرانيا لوقف الحرب
وتنضم الينا من جزيره بالي الاندونيسيه
مفضله العربيه الجميله ناديه البلبيسي
مرحبا بك ناديه ناديه نريد ان نتوقف امام
البيان الختامي لمجموعه العشرين واستخدام
بعض العبارات حينما تم الحديث عن ان معظم
الدول الاعضاء تدين الحرب يعني استخدام
معظم وفي النهايه من الناحيه المنطقيه تظل
هذه العباره عباره جزئيه لا تشمل الجميع
ايضا البيان حمل بعض التعبيرات بمفردات
مختلفه في حين قالوا احيانا ناسف في
احيانا اخرى قالوا ندين يبدو ان الصياعه
كانت مرتبكه لارتباك المواقف دعينا في
الصوره
تمام رشا حدا يعكس الانقسام الذي شهدناه
على هامش هذه القمه اللي هي من المفروض ان
تكون اقتصاديه في الدرجه الاولى تتحدث عن
البنيه التحتيه عن التضخم على المشاريع
لتحسين تغيير المناخ والتعامل معه
وطبعا هيكله الديون للدول الناميه لكن
الموضوع او المواضيع السياسيه وبالتحديد
الحرف اوكرانيا القت بظلالها على هذه
القمه رغم انه حتى رئيس ودوده نفسه كان
يقول باننا لسنا بمنظمه امنيه تحل كل
المشاكل العالم لكن عندما نقول بان بعض
الدول دانت الغزوه الروسي نتحدث عن
الولايات المتحده ومجموعه السبع الصناعيه
والشراك التي خلقها الرئيس لتضم ايضا
استراليا واليابان وكندا هذه هي المجموعه
التي وقفت منذ اليوم الاول مع اوكرانيا
اعتبرت الغزو الروسي انتهاك سافر لقوانين
الامم المتحده والقانون الدولي وقالت علنا
بانها تق المساعدات العسكريه وتقدم
المساعدات الاقتصاديه لاوكرانيا الدول
الاخرى باقي دول العشرين مثل الصين
والبرازيل والارجنتين والهند وغيرها نوعا
ما يعني تاخذ مسافه من موقف واشنطن وتقول
بانها وافقت على ان الغزو الروسي ادى الى
هشاشه الاقتصاد العالمي واثر على الامن
الغذائي وعلى امن الطاقه لكن لا تذهب
باستخدام هذه العبارات كما تفعل مجموعه
الاتحاد الاوروبي طبعا مجموعه الدول همم
السبعه الصناعيه بقياده الولايات المتحده
لكن ما حدث هذا الصباح ربما كانت الصعيد
في الموقف الروسي رغم ان همم الولايات
المتحده تتريه نوعا ما وقالت بانها ستنتظر
نتائج التحقيق حول اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
الروسيه على المدن الاوكرانيه والتي طالت
ايضا همم مدينه او قريه في بولندا وكما
تعرفين هذا يؤدي الى حاله من الرعب في
شمال هناك موضوع مهم للغايه في هذا الحلف
هناك موضوع مهم للغايه كان حاضرا وبقوه في
هذه القمه وهي ازمه الغذاء العالميه
واتفاق اعاده تصدير الحبوب الذي توقف خلال
الفتره الماضيه وتداعته الخطيره هل يمكن
ان يكون هناك عنوان رئيسيه حول ما هو
القادم بشان هذه الازمهها الحدث توافق بين
القاده في هذا الملف
هناك توافق لكن بالنهايه اذا ارادت روسي
ان تعطل هذا الاتفاق او العمل به بامكانها
ان تفعل ذلك همم لذا هناك حرس من قبل ربما
الاطراف المشاركه وبالتحديد ربما الدور
التركي الذي قال الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
بانه يريد ان يلعب دور وسلطه لانهاء هذه
الحرب وتاثيراتها الكارثيه على الامن
الغذائي كما نعرف اوكرانيا من مصدرين
الاوائل القمح والحبوب وحتى منطقه الشرق
الاوسط تعتمد عليها بشكل اساس وبالتالي
التاثير على الامن الغذائي هو بسبب هذه
الحرب ومن هنا اعتقد كان هناك اجماع على
ان التاثيرات والتداريات لهذه الحرب بتطلع
الجميع لكن اعتقد منه هناك اتفاق على
الاقل مبدئي بانه همم يجب تجديد العمل في
هذا الاتفاق لكن كما راينا يمكن ان اي خلل
بالنسبه همم كان همم
على قنوات الاتصال المفتوحه مع روسيا او
ان روسيا تاخذ موقف معين يمكن ان يؤثر
بشكل كبير على تصدير او رئيس الصاله هذه
الحبوب
وعلاقتها بالامن الغذائي زميلتي ناديه
البلبيسي المفضله العربيه من جزيره بالي
الاندونيسيه حيث ناققات قمه ال 20 شكرا لك
ناديه
ونبقى معكم في سياق نشاط الظهيره من
العربيه ولدينا فرنسا تؤكد ضروره التزام
اقصى درجه من الحظر بشان مصدر صاروخ الذي
سقط في هولندا وتحذر من خطر الصعيد كبير
اهلا بكم من جديد
نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان النتائج
الاوليه تشير الى ان صاروخ الذي ضرب
بولندا تم اطلاقه من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه وذلك الاعتراض على صاروخ
الروسي وهو ما يعزز التصريحات التي ادلى
بها رئيس بيدن بشان الهجوم الصاروخيه
همم انسان مايكرويف 5
قاده مجموعه السبع والنيتو على هامش قمه
ال 20 في بالي حيثيات سقوط الصاروخ داخل
الاراضي البولنديه واكد بيان في ختام
الاجتماعي ان القاده اتفقوا على دعم
التحقيقات التي تجريها بولندا في هذا
الصدد كما اتفقت الدول على البقاء على
اتصال وتنسيق الخطوات القادمه البيان
وادانا الهجمات الروسيه في اوكرانيا واصفا
اياها بالبربريه كما اكد دعمك المستمر
الى ذلك بعد فرنسا على ضروره التزام اقصى
درجه من الحذر بشان مصدر الصاروخ الذي سقط
في بولندا محذره من خطر تصعيد كبير على حد
وصفها واكدت رئاسه الفرنسيه في بيان لها
ان الدول عده في المنطقه تمتلك النوع نفسه
من الاسلحه معتبره ان تحديد نوع الصاروخ
لا يعني بالضروره تحديد الجهه التي اطلق
منها فيما اعتبر المستشار الالمانيه
التحقق من كيفيه حدوث هذه الحادثه المروعه
في حين دعت الصين جميع الاطراف الى ضبط
النفس
في بولندا قال رئيس البولندي انه ليس لديه
ادله دامغه حول مصدر الصاروخين اللذين سقط
على اراضي بولندا وانه لا يوجد اي مؤشرات
على احتمال تكرار ما حدث رئيس البولندي
اشار الى انه يتم التعامل مع قضيه سقوط
الصاروخين بشكل هادئ مرجحا ان تطلب بلاده
تفعيل الماده الرابعه من ميثاق الميتو
خلال اجتماع الحلف اليوم
في غضون ذلك اعتبر رئيس الاوكرانيه
ان حادثه صاروخ بولندا رساله من روسيا الى
قمه العشرين وكان زنسكي قد اعتبر ان
الحادث تصعيد كبير وتهديد للامن العالمي
ويستدعي تحرك حلف شمال الاطلسي
طويله لقد قلنا ان الارهاب لا يقتصر على
حدود دولهنا بل انه يمتد بالفعل الى اراضي
منظفه واليوم ضربت صواريخ روسيه بولندا
اراضي دوله خليفه كلما طالت المده التي
تشعر خلالها روسيا بهذه الحصانه والافلام
من العقاب كلما زادت التهديدات التي
تستهدف جميع منهم في مرمى الصواريخ
الروسيه اطلاق الصواريخ على الاراضى هو
هجوم الروسيه على الامن الجماعي هذا تصعيد
كبير جدا ويجب ان نتحرك
وينضم الينا من ثياب مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل مرحبا بك حذيفه الموقف يشهد تجارب
كبير في المعلومات ما هي السوره من داخل
اوكرانيا هناك بعض المعلومات التي تشير
الى ان الصاروخ الذي نزل او الصاروخين
اللذين سقط في بولندا كان من خلال صاروخ
اوكراني يعترض صاروخ روسي ما هي المعلومات
المتوفره
حتى هذه اللحظه من الجانب الاخراني لا
يوجد تصريح حول هويه الصاروخ او اذا كان
همم المسؤول عن هذه الحادثه في منطقه لهم
في بولندا هي القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
وكان عمليه اعتراضها وغيره ذلك ولكن طبعا
القياده العسكريه والقياده السياسيه في
البلاد اتفقت على ان هذا الاستهداف الذي
يحتمل طبعا ان يكون من قبل القوات الروسيه
التي استهدف طبعا منطقه نمو المتاخمه
لمنتخبتهم
عدد كبير من الصواريخ في هذه المنطقه اتفق
ال- ال-
الجميع في مرمى الصواريخ الروسيه وان
الاتحاد الروسي الذي يقف عند همم حدود
الحدود الوطنيه اوكرانيا وانما بعد الفراغ
من اوكرانيا وقد يزحف في اتجاه الدول
الاوروبيه بولندا ورومانيا بشكل
قبره طبعا تضامن واا جرى اتصال هاتفي بينه
وبين الرئيس البولندي دوده وعبر له عن
التعازي وايضا شكرا هل نفت اوكرانيا
الروايه التي تتحدث عن صاروخ اوكراني كان
الاعتراض صاروخ روسي هو الذي ادى الى سقوط
الصواريخ في هولندا هل نفت اوكرانيا رسميا
هذه الروايه
ولا يوجد نفي ولكن توجد بعض التصريحات
التي من بعض القيادات التي يقولون فيها
انه يجب ان يعني تنتظر ينتظر جميع
التحقيقات التي الجاريه الان حتى اثبات
هويه هذا الصاروخ ذلك عند السيناريوهات
هنالك سيناري وان يكون هذا الصاروخ ثم
اطلاقه من اراضي الروسيه والحديث يدور عن
تخطيط لجر بلا روسيا لهذه الحرب عن طريق
انشاء تهديد همم بين بولندا ايضا ال- ال-
ال- الحديث يدور عن ان الاستهداف مباشره
اي تصعيد من قبلته
عكس روايات التي تقال خارج لتوضيح
نعم نعم هذا صحيح وايضا عن ان الصاروخ قد
يكون قد سقط بالخطا لانه هنالك استهداف في
منطقه المنتخبه وتم استضافه بما يزيد عن
العشر الصواريخ في مناطق مختلفه استهدفت
الفيديو التحتيه للطاقه طبعا بالامس تم
اطلاق 100 صاروخ للاراضي الاوكرانيه
استهدفها 17 ولايه خرجت عن التغطيه 15
محطه للكهرباء فقد يكون انه لا ان هذا هذه
الصواريخ قد وصلت عن طريق
ان هذه الصواريخ الروسيه القديمه التي
تستخدم الان في هذه الحرب بنسبه كبيره هي
ليست الدقيقه بشكل كبير يعني دائما نشد ان
يكون هناك استهداف همم
الطاقه ولكن الصواريخ الطاقه في منطقه
اخرى قريبه من هذه المنطقه وتستهدف بعض
المناطق السكنيه المهوله بالسكان وهذا ما
حدث بالامس ثم استهداف ثلاثه مواقع داخل
العاصمه كيف منطقه واحده منهم سقط فيها
صاروخ بعد ان تم اعتراضه من قبل الدفاع
نعم اذا نحن امام روايات مختلفه روايات في
الداخل الاوكراني تقول عكس الروايات
الاخرى وبالتالي تحميل المسؤوليه لكلى
الطرفين لم يتقطع حتى اللحظه وفقا لما هو
منشور زميلي حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه من
ثياب شكرا لك
في هذا السياقه اعتبر مندوب روسيا بالعمم
المتحده فزيلي نيفيا حادثه سقوط صاروا في
بولندا محاوله لاثاره مواجهه عسكريه
مباشره ما بين روسيا وحلفيتو وقال في
تصريحات صحفيه ان بلاده ليس لديها اي
علاقه بسقوط صاروخ في بولندا وان الحقائق
تشير الى ان الصاروخ انطلق من خارج روسيا
وانضم الينا من موسكو المحلل السياسي في
جينيسيس روفر مرحبا بك سيدي صحيح ان
الحاضر هو سيد الموقف وليست هناك معلومات
محدده لكن هناك اشارات من اوكرانيا تحمل
روسيا مسؤوليه سقوط هذا الصاروخ في بولندا
كيف تتعامل موسكو مع هذا التطور الجديد
صاروخين اا في بلده بولنديه بهدوء تام
لانها تدرك تماما انا هناك استفزازادا
متعمدا من قبل بعض الدول والاطراف التي
تريده اللقاء بين روسيا والناته لكي تدخل
المواجهه بينهما وهي غير مباشره حتى الان
الى صدام العسكريه مباشره هذا الامر لا
يتفق ليلي مصالح روسيا وليلى ما صالح
الدول والولايات المتحده قبل اي شيء اخر
وليس من قبيل الصدفه ان الرئيس
قال ان المعلومات المتوفره حتى تلك الساعه
همم لا تشير الى ان روسيا لديها ضلع في
مثل هذه الحادثه وبالتالي ليس هناك همم
يعني همم
مسار الصاروخ لا يشير الى انه قد يكون قد
انطلق من روسيا يعني هذا على ما يبدو هو
تقديم الاستخبارات الامريكيه له
وبالمناسبه الاستخبارات الامريكيه هنا
ربما اردت دقه في اا يعني دراستها
وتحليلاتها
ولابد هنا من اضافه شيء مهمه وهو انه جرى
مؤخرا في تركيا لقاء بين مسؤولين
الاستخباراتين همم المسؤولين
الاستخباراتين الروسي والامريكي ورغم ما
في همم
بانهما بحث او تبحث في الازمه الاوكرانيه
الى انه من الوضع ان هناك قناه همم يعني
ساخنه او خط ساخن بين الدولتين ويمكن من
خلاله هو التبادل باخر المعلومات بهذا
الشهر واعتقد بان ماله روسيا من الادله
على عدم توردها في هذه الحادث ربما اقنع
الجانب الامريكي للتواصل الى نفسه روايه
الروسي كيف يمكن ان تكون رده فعل روسيا
اذا ما اقبل النت على استخدام الماده
الرابعه من ميثاق انيتوا الخاصه بتفعيل
القوى اذا ما تعرضت اي احد همم او احدى
الدول العضو النيتولي اي اعتداء
فقط سوف تتصرف بحزم وسترد همم على اي
استهداف للاراضي الروسيه بشكل حازم دون
تردد ولكن يعني الاحاديث في هذا الشهر
كلها تحمله طبعا الافتراضيه او نظريا لانه
مثل هذا التطور في موسكو لا يعتبرونه
تطورا واقعيا وواضح تماما ان الدول التي
لها علاقه بهذا الموضوع هو للناته هو
المعسكر الغربي بشكل عام يدرس بعمق لكي لا
يعطي يعني اي فريق اولئك الذين ربما
يسرعون ويستبقون الحوادث ويريدون القاء
لهما على روسيا في هذا الشهر
استخدم رئيس الروسيه السابقه
اشارات واضحه مثلا حينما تم تفجير خط
النار انه هناك اطراف تحاول العبث في
العلاقه ما بين روسيا والدول الاوروبيه هل
هذه الحادثه يمكن ان تكون في نفس السياق
ايضا
نعم لا شك انها تندرج في نفس السياق
وهناققي وليشك انها مهتمه بدق سفينه في
العلاقات بين روسيا والتعميق هو هذه
الخلافات ليسيه ما الان في ظل تباعد شديد
تبين اثناء القمه باليه رغم ان هناك
اختلافا كبيرا في الاراء حول الازمه
الاوكرانيه
وحول روسيا في هذا الشان وبالتالي اعتقد
بان بالفعل هذه القصه ربما سوف تستغلها
تلك لهساطه التي تريد ان تجر روسيا والدول
الناتو في مواجهه عسكريه مباشره
مع سيد يبقيني يا سيد روفا المحلل السياسي
من موسكو تحياتي
ايه الشان الامريكيه اعلن رئيس الامريكي
السابق ترامب ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
لعام 20 24 وقال من منتجع مراراغو في
فلوريدا انه سيخوض سباق للبيت الابيض
للمره الثالثه واشارت وكاله الانباء باينه
ترامب قدم اورقه رشحه بالفعل يوم الجمعه
امام هيئه الانتخابات الفيدراليه
الامريكيه
نحن هنا اليوم لنعلنا انه ليس بالضروره ان
يبقى الوضع على ما هو عليه قبل عامين كنا
امه عظيمه وقريبا سنكون امه عظيمه من جديد
عام 2024 هو الموعد لتصويت افضل هل انتم
مستعدون وانا ايضا مستعد ساضمن عدم حصول
بيض على اربعه اعوام اخرى بلادنا لا
يمكنها ان تتحمل ذلك انني اعلن اليوم
ترشيح نفسي لمنصب رئيس الولايات المتحده
في الجوله المقبله
وفي اول رد فعل الرئيس الامريكي جباين على
اعلان ترامب بترشحه مره اخرى للانتخابات
الرئاسيه قلب ايضا ان ترامب خذل بلاده
خلال توليه منصبه بيض كتب في تغريده من
بالي ان ترامب وخلال رئاسته تربع على
اقتصاد المزور لصالح الاثرياء هاجم النظام
الصحي دلل المتطرفين هاجم حقوق المراه حرض
العصابات العنيفه من اجل محاوله قلب فوزي
بيض عام 2020 الى خساره وفقا لتصنيفاته
بيضا في تغريدته
هذا وتسربت معلومات منذ اسابيع ان وزاره
العدل الامريكيه تسعى لتوجيه تهمل الرئيس
السابق ترامب في قضيه الوثائق السريه التي
بحوزته لكنها تؤجل ذلك الى ما بعد الاعلان
الرسمي لنتائج الانتخابات التجديد النصفي
في امريكا
على اهتمامه وزاره العدل الامريكيه منذ
اشهر وتسربت معلومات بدايه الشهر تشير الى
ان المحققين ربما يوجهون توهما للرئيس
السابق في هذه القضيه
الرئيس
كان قراره وليس بالخطا او بدون علمه ربما
لا يكون وجود الاوراق السريه وفيها
معلومات عن البرامج النوويه لدول اجنبيه
في مقر الرئيس السابق سببا كافيا لتوجيه
تهمه اليه من قبل وزاره العدل انما عدم
تعاونه المشكله
ممكن جدا على اساس ان من يحتفظ بوثائق
تتعلق بالامن القومي من واجبه تسليمها
لممثلين الدوله عندما يطلب منه ذلك
سيكون توجيه التهم المحتمله تحدي كبير
للرئيس السابق لكنها ليست نهايه المطاف في
حين يتعرض لاكثر من ملاحقه قانونيه
الاتهامات لو حصل هجوما من الدوله العميقه
لمنع الرئيس من العوده الى البيت الابيض
فسيكون لهم موقف مختلف
[تصفيق]
الرئيس السابق سيستعمل ذلك كاسبات يقدمه
لمؤيده على ان الطبقه السياسيه تعتبره
تحديدا وستفعل اي شيء لمنعه من العوده الى
البيت الابيض
الاندفاع السياسي ايا كانت الظروف
القانونيه في الرئيس ترامب يحظى بتايدا
حار من قبل قاعدته والهدف هو والعوده الى
البيت الابيض
من واشنطن الخبير في شان الامريكي والبحث
في العلاقات الدوليه سيد ايهاب عباس مرحبا
بك سيد ايهاب توقيت اعلان ترامب بمساله
ترشحه البعض يعتقد انه اختار لحظه لا
يتمتع فيها بالقوه الكافيه لهذا الاعلان
خاصه ان التقديرات تشير الى ان من دعمهم
في انتخابات التجديد النصفي معظمهم اخفق
اهلا بكل المشاهدين
هناك طبعا من يذهب الى هذا الاعتقاد وهناك
من يذهب لاعتقاد اخر وروي اخرى وهي ان اا
ليس كل من دعامهم الريزونالد ترامب في
الانتخابات قد ايه فشل هناك جزء منهم نجاح
بالاضافه الى انه همم الحزب الجمهوري لم
يفشل في المطلق كما يروج الديمقراطيون هو
استطاع ان اا يفوز همم حزب بمجلس النواب
بشكل خلاص حاسس ان تقريبا
وهذا يعدوا انتصارا على الديمقراطيين همم
لكن بالفعل هناك همم داخل الولايات
المتحده في الواقع تحديدا من التيار
الديمقراطي التقدمي اليه يساري من هم
يحاولون ان يظهروا الجمهوريين وكانهم خاسر
الانتخابات بكل تاكيد لا هي ليست خساره
وهم يسيطرون اليوم على مجلس النواب وستجد
الايام القادمه صعبه عليهم لان مجلس
النواب
ترامب على ماذا يراهن هل
يتمتع بنفس ما كان يتمتع به من قاعده
واسعه وتاييد كبير داخل الحزب الجمهوري
لان هناك من يقول ان ستكون هناك حسابات
مختلفه لدى الحزب الجمهوري حول من تحديدا
سيكون مرشحه في الانتخابات القادمه
يريدون دماء جديد
ووجوها جديد واستراتيجيات جديده لذلك همم
برزسم همم حاكم لاعب فلوريدا السيد راندي
سانتوس خلال الفتره القليله جدا الماضيه
كم منافس محتمل بشكل كبير للرئيس رونالد
واا ايضا اي مترشح اخر على الحزب الجمهوري
هناك اسماء بكل تاكيد ستظهر الفتره
القليله القادمه ل- اا يعني نفسها وهمم
وخوض سباق الاحتماليه بتاعه الترشح عن
الحزب الجمهوري الرئيس رونالد ترامب يتمتع
بقاعده شعبيه عريضه مصر الامريكي تقريبا
ذهبوا للانتخابه في قبل عامين في
الانتخابات
في هذه القاعده ان فقد جزء منها
يعني هذا ستجيب عنه صناديق الاقتراع في
الواقع لكن انا من وجهه نظري انه اكيد فقد
جزء منها بسبب الاحداث التي وقعت فيها
الرئيس في تغريداته قال ان ترامب تسبب في
وجود اقتصاد مصور لصالح الاثريات هاجم
النظام الصحي دلل المتطرفين هاجم حقوق
المراه حرض العصابات العنيفه شاكك في
الانتخابات يعني هذه مجموعه طويله من
القائمه التي تحدث عنها
طيب ايه نشير فقط اجابه هذا السؤال ولكن
سننتقل الان الى كلمه لرئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه ريشي سوناك على هامش قمه ال 20
يجب ان نكون واضحين بان اي من هذا المكان
الذي يحدث
لولا العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا هذا هو
الواقعه القاسيه علينا والذي يجب ان لا
نتجنبه
كما تستمر هذه الحرب فانها تشكل تهديدا
لامننا وكذلك لامن حلفائنا ولا طالما هي
مستمره ستواصل تدميرها للاقتصاد الدوليه
اعضاء مجموعه العشرين يعانون من معدلات
تضخم اكثر من سبعه بالمئه وسيكون هناك
ركود في العالم
عام او الذي يليه
كلنا بالكاد خرجنا من الجائحه
العقوبه كانت بمواجهه هذا المستقبل
الضربات الاقتصاديه والازمات الاقتصاديه
دائما ما تكون عالميه اتينا معا واستمرينا
معا على الرغم من اختلافاتنا في اعترافنا
لاهميه الجانب الاقتصادي لهذا المنتدى لكن
هذا العام كما اش- اكدت همم احداث ليله
امس الوضع هو سياسي
وتهديد المتواصل على امننا همم
هو ما يدفع كلنا ان نكون في هذه القمه فلا
تدمر
ما من احد لم يشعر باثار حرب بوتن على
اسواق الغذاء العالميه التي
كتاب السبب
انقطاع الواردات من الحبوب الاوكرانيه
وكذلك بوقف الغاز
الروسي
علينا من ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
ان الاستقرار
والثقه في الاقتصاد
الاقتصاديه وهذا يجعل الدول الاعضاء
تعمل جاهده لخفض الاسعار وايجاد الفرس
والظروف
الاقتصادي بريطانيا والاقتصادات العالميه
لان تعود بها وكذلك تعزيز الاسس
الاقتصاديه الدوليه والقيام بالالتزامات
لمساعده الاكثر هشاشه
وتقليل الاعتماد على الوقود الاحفوري
الروسي وايجاد البدائل واجاز المستقبل في
حين انهما من دوله
قادره بمفردها انتم تقود الاقتصاد العالمي
او غدا اشكر الرئيس الاندونيسي في
الاستضافه هذه القمه
ومواجهه التحديات واا سندني همم على هذه
الاسس ونضع خطته للجل الدوله
بارشاداته
الناميه
وعلاقاتنا وامننا بهذا سنبضي منصه دوليه
لتنتعش فيها بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
التي يحتاجونها شكرا لكم
البي بي سي
شكرا لك
همم سي الرئيس بوتين قال ان هذه انا
الصواريخ التي يقال انها في بولندا على
الاراضي بولنديه انا اساسها روسي قال انها
ليست كذلك
هل يمكن ان يدفع ذلك
وكلنا اتفقنا هذا الصباح انه مهم جدا
لفرقنا لان تضع الوقائع هناك فرق على
الارض تقوم
شكرا شكرا
وسنتريك عمليه التحقيق تنتهي لنعرف
نتيجتها وجود هذا الحوار هو بسبب ان
روسيا اطلقت اكثر من 80 صاروخ على البناء
تحتيه وعلى المدنيين في اوكرانيا
عندما استيقظت في الخامس صباحا
وسمعت عن هذه الصواريخ التي وصلت على
مقربه من بولندا هل هذا دفعك لمزيد من
القلق
رد فعل كان اتصالي برائيس بولندا
في ما يحتاجونه
بلدي هو اول ان اشير ان ما وقع يوم امس هو
امر
صعب وتحدث الى
الرئيسكي
وتحدثنا حول ما يحدث على الاراضي
الاوكرانيين اكثر من 80 صاروخ
هذا ما يحدث وهذا كان يحدث في الوقت الذي
كانت تجتمع فيه مجموعه ال20 لمحاوله
التوصل الى حلول لتحديات العالم لكنه همم
اختار يعني بوتن ااه ان همم
يطلق صواريقه على اوكرانيا في ذلك الوقت
وبالتالي
ابراهيم ابراهيم
وبالتالي تحدثنا في اجتماعاتنا عن هذه
الهجمات
الهجره القسريه
[موسيقى]
الذي نواجهه على اراضينا
سلايم
انزعاج بين افراد الشعب لانهم يبقون
قلقينا من تسديد فواتيرهم
واهم شيء ان نقول له ان هذا هو تحدي عالمي
ولهذا خذنا بنقاشات مع القيادات التي تحضر
هذه القمه وتحدثنا عن همم
رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه على هامشي قمه
العشرين والتي اكد فيها وبشكل المباشر
عبارات واضحه حمل فيها بوتين مسؤوليه
الركود الاقتصاديه وقسمتي الثقه والغذاء
التي اصابت العالم وفي اجابته على عدد من
اسئله الصحفيين التي ركزت بشكل كبير على
سقوط صاروخ في هولندا قال ريشه هناك ان
هناك تحقيقات تجرى وليست هناك اجابات
واضحه حتى اللحظه ولكنه اشاره في خضامن
عرضه ل- مواقف متعدده ان روسيا سبق واطلقت
اكتر من 80 صاروخا على البنا التحتيه
الاوكرانيه بالامس فقط وبالتالي قال انه
صرع بالاتصال برئيس بولندا لتاكيد تضامن
بريطانيا مع بولندا في هذا الشهر
ونبقى معكم في سياق نشاط ظاهره من العربيه
ولدينا
نسى تطلق صاروخا نحو القمر للمره الاولى
منذ نصف قرن
واي فاي
نواصلوا مع حضراتكم نشره الظهيره من
العربيه اعلنت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه عن
مقتل عقيد في الحرس الثوري واثنين من رجال
الامن في اعمال عنف وقعت بثلاث مدن
ايرانيه فيما كشفت لجنه حمايه الصحفيين
على اعتقال مالا يقل عن 62 صحفيا من خلال
قائمه نشرتها تحمل اسماء الصحفيين
المحتجزين منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه واوضحت اللجنه ان هذه
القائمه اعدت بناء على المصادر الاخباريه
لجنه حمايه الصحفيين في ايران والنقابه
صحفيه طيران مضيفه ان سلطات الايرانيه
افرجات عن 14 من هؤلاء الصحفيين فقط وذلك
بعد دفع كفاله واعتقلت احدهما مره اخرى
الى ذلك استدعت وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه
سفير استراليا بسبب تصريحات ادلى بها رئيس
الوزراء الاسترالي تدعم الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه حسب وكاله نور نيوز وقال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني ان رئيسه وزراء استراليا يبدو انه
اتخذ نهجا بناء على معلومات كاذبه وهو شيء
ليس في مصلحه العلاقه بين البلدين هذا
ومنذ بدء الاحتجاجات في ايران قبل اكثر من
شهرين بعد وفاه مساء اماني استدعى تهران
العديد من السفراء الاجانب بسبب تعليقات
بشان دعم هذه الاحتجاجات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا طويل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ونشير الى هذا العجل وفقا للاسف بريس هناك
هجوم بمسيره على ناقله نفط قباله سواحل
عمان هذا هو العجل الذي تتابعون الان على
شاشه العربيه هجوم بمسيره على ناقله نفط
قبله ساحل عمان نعود مره اخرى لمتابعه
عشان الايراني والاحتجاجات الايرانيه
وانضم الينا من لندن الباحثه عشان
الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن مرحبا بك سيد
وجدان الى نشره الظهيره في العربيه نبدا
به مساله الاحتجاجات والقمع والقبض على
وشاهدنا هذه الفيديوهات الموفقه لقيام
اجهزه الامن بالقبض على عدد كبير من
المحتاجين الامراه اخر يتعلق بمصادر تشير
الى انه ستبدا حمله اعدامات لعدد من
المحتاجين الذين تم القبض عليهم الى اي
مدى يسم ذلك في همم اشارات سيئه حول سجل
حقوق الانسان في ايران
طبعا السجل ايران بالنسبه
للاعدامات هو سيء منذ بدايه الثوره ارتكب
النظام الايراني مجازر كبيره وعديده ولا
يمنى هذا فهذا ليس مستبعدا ان ترتكب همم
هكذا جرائم بحق حقوق الانسان
ونعرف انه كل هذه الاعتراضات التي اخذت هي
تحت التعذيب ولا يمكن اعتبارها
احترافات حقيقيه لكن فيما يتعلق بموضوع
الاحتجاجات
ما نشهده اليوم هو اليوم تجاوز عن موضوع
الاحتجاجات اليوم ااا
تمر ايران بثوره حقيقيه انتفض فيها كل
الاطياف وكل الاجيال وايضا
اطياف ان مختلفه من عمال الى طلبه جامعه
ساجده جامعه موظفين دوائر الحكوميه
المدارس وكل هذه هي الاطيار لذلك نحن في
مرحله همم ثوره لكن هذه القرارات او هذه
همم
الاعدامات التي يحاول النظام الايراني
تخويف الشارع
وتدخل شعرها الثاني وان ربما هذا سهم بشكل
كبير في اهتزاز سوره النظام الايراني لكنه
ليس مؤشر وحده على امكانيه سقوط هذا
النظام
هو دخول الشهر الثالث لكن فيما يتعلق
بموضوع اييي
الاحتجاجات هي بالفعل الان بدات هذه
الثوره ولا اشياء كانها ستاخذ وقتا طويلا
لينا الم نشهد في السابق احتجاجيه بهذا
المستوى او ترتغى الى موضوع الثوره لذلك
انها تاخذ بعض الوقت لان حتى الان
همم الدول
التي تدعي الدفاع عن حقوق الانسان بصراحه
حتى الان لم تحضر بقوه للدفاع عن ما يحصل
داخل العراق
جلسه في مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع للامم
المتحده لادانه هذا الامر كانت هناك دعوه
تقدمت بها المانيا وايسلندا
نعم هذا هذا الامر هو مهم جدا
وايضا هذا ما كنا يعني كشارع ايراني كان
ينتظر لهكذا قرارات ولكن حتى هذا الاجتماع
رغم انه مهم جدا لكن لن يكون كافيه لان
حتى الان كل هذه القرارات التي بدات تاخذ
انها قرارات سياسيه فقط لم تكن همم
العقوبات ليس كافيه لان النظام الايراني
ايضا فرضت عليها العديد من العقوبات نحن
او الشارع يطالب بها ان تكون العقوبات
اولا تشمل الحرس الثوري الايراني برمه
لانه هو من يقوم بقمع الاحتجاجات الامر
الثاني ان تكون هنالك قرارات لطرد السفراء
في الدول الغربيه
للضغط على النظام الايراني
من لندن شكرا لك ونعود مره اخرى لمتابعه
العاجل على شاشه
اخرى تضرر في ناقله التي تعرضت لهجوم
بمسيره في ساحل عمان همم الانباء تشير الى
ضرر ما قد وقع بالفعل في ناقله النفط الذي
او التي تعرضت لهجوم بمصيره همم في القبله
سواحل عمان عمان
مليار دولار لمساعده معاناه الدول من
الازمه ازمه الجائحه
فرنسيشن
من برنامج الانتقال بقيمته 20 مليون دولار
التزامات الضخمه هذه
التي تشكل
30% من
يعني
البحار العالميه ستكون محميه بحلول
20 30 وسيكون هناك
تدهور الاراضي
وهذا يعتبر
اتفاق مهم
فهناك الكثير من الاتفاقات الملموسه التي
توصلنا اليها اعتقد هذا كل ما لدينا
عنوان
الى ان هناك سؤال من اندونيسيا وسؤال من
الاعلام الدولي تفضل
هناخذ الصحافه على الاندلسيه اولا
شكرا
سؤال سؤال
عن ضربات صاروخيه في بولندا
تخشون ان هذه
الضربات قد شتت اجنده همم مجموعه العشرين
بدايه
انا اسف على الحادثه التي وقعت في بولندا
وادعوا جميع الاطراف لان تبقى
هادئه وانت تتوقف
عن زياده التوتر
كما انني
قلت دوما ان الحرب
ستجلب فقط الدمار
لذلك
علينا ان نوقف الحرب
لوقف الدمار والى ضبط النفس في التعامل مع
اجمل صواريخ بولندا
التي تعرضت لهجوم بمسيره قبل سواحل عمان
والاسطول الخامس الامريكيه يقول انه تلقى
تقريبا
بتعرض ناقله لهجوم بمصيره
سنظل في متابعه دعايات هذا الامر ولكن
الناقله تضررت بالفعل وفقا لما هو منشور
في الشهداء وصلنا لختامين نشاط ظاهره من
العربيه الى اللقاء